Here's the quiz I'd like to give you--what I've provided is a queue code
we've already seen and also three test functions.
The first test function is the one that I wrote and this is put here really quickly.
It creates a three-element queue, checks that it's empty that is to save.
It calls the empty method, and if it's not empty, that is to save.
If the empty method doesn't return true, we print test1 not okay and return.
Otherwise, we keep going. So we enqueue a 10, make sure that that succeeds.
Enqueue the value 11, make sure that that succeeds.
Call dequeue method which takes the first thing out of the queue that we put in
which is 10, so we make sure that it's 10.
Dequeue the next element, make sure that it is 11, and now we check again that the queue is empty.
If all of these are true, then we print test1 okay. So, that's my test function.
You're test function are test2 and 3--so just make sure that everything works here.
We run the code and we see the test1 okay, test2 okay, and test3 okay.
So you're assignment is to write functions test2 and test3.
So just a little bit previously, I gave some examples
of several different tasks for the queue that were equivalent to each other
in the sense that if we run one of them then it would just about as good as running the other one.
So, if you remember, for example, we can enqueue some numbers
and dequeue them and check if they are correct.
The queue code would behave exactly the same
if we do the same exact operations but with sleeps in between them.
So, you're going to do here is the opposite of what I was showing.
What I want you to do is write test functions two and three
so they're not testing equivalent functionality in the queue.
This should be pretty easy but let me just go up and look at the code
and we'll get some ideas about how that might work.
So, what kind of behaviors in the code could you trigger that I didn't trigger?
Well, it's pretty obvious. For example, I never triggered the four case for enqueue.
I never triggered the wrap around case, I never triggered the empty case for dequeue,
nor did I trigger the wrap around case with the head point.
So, given those ideas, right functions test2 and test3 such that
they are not testing equivalent queue functionality as the test1 function that I wrote.